The Avengers: Endgame team is still happy
they put the film's ladies in formation.
In Slashfilm's definitive oral history of
the movie's enormous, climactic battle sequence,
Endgame co-writers Stephen McFeely and Christopher
Markus, editor Jeff Ford, and executive producer
Trinh Tran defended the decision to feature
all of the women of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in one shot — a moment that sparked controversy
among some fans.
Female superheroes have been an integral part
of the MCU for years.
However, the headlining superheroes throughout
the MCU's films have all been men, with Captain
Marvel as the only current exception.
But with Captain Marvel confirmed as the MCU's
most powerful hero ...
… and with Black Widow's standalone prequel
movie forthcoming, this year was time for
these Marvel-ous women to finally get their
due, and the writers wanted to pay homage
to all of the incredible females in the MCU
during Endgame.
Tran said the moment was nothing short of
magical, especially thanks to the on-set audience:
For his part, Ford recalled that the filming
process was awe-inspiring and so rewarding.
He noted that the sequence was "one of the
most amazing things [he'd] ever seen" and
the work that went into it was nothing short
of impressive, adding,
"They brought so much attitude to that thing
that was just right on.
We shot that shot about four or five times.
It was all we could do, because it was crazy
-- it was really hard to do, because it involved
the camera moving on this small stage to get
enough running time.
It wasn't a huge stage, but they ran a lot,
so we had to run them on this thing and the
rigging was really difficult to pull off."
When the Endgame team got the take they were
after, the cast and crew erupted in celebration.
As Ford tells it,
"We got through it, and there was a big cheer,
and everybody was super happy, and all of
the women on the set got together and took
a group photo.
I thought that was just the coolest thing
ever.
I had chills that moment."
Those remarks come after Markus and McFeely
opened up to the New York Times in May 2019
about the scene.
McFeely noted that the team "like[d] it too
much" to get rid of it, even with the risk
of it coming across as fan-service-y, while
Markus said that "part of the fun of the Avengers
movies has always been team-ups," and the
"badass women" deserved that kind of moment.
Endgame co-director Anthony Russo also said
of the scene,
"Looking back on the entire road that the
MCU has traveled, it just struck us how many
amazing female characters have entered the
[franchise].
I think it was really, for us, a moment of
celebration and acknowledgment of the intensity
and empowerment in that."
As amazing as the Endgame team felt the all-female
scene was, the question still stood: Was it
a pandering effort to prove that the MCU is
female-friendly?
Ford admitted that he had his doubts about
the sequence early on, and Markus chimed in
to share a hilarious moment that happened
during a test screening, which ultimately
confirmed for him that the girl-power scene
needed to stay in Endgame.
Markus said,
"Literally, one of the comments at a test
screening was, 'It's pandering.
Don't you dare cut it."
McFeely's overall perspective on the scene's
importance was the most resonant:
"Emotional logic wins every time.
So I recognize that there are some people
who are like, 'it's pretty convenient that
all of the ladies are all in one spot,' but
the eight-year-old girl next to me loses her
mind and wears a T-shirt, and I'm good with
it."
In the aftermath of Endgame's release, many
audience members felt that one brief moment
just wasn't enough service to the amazing
women of Marvel — especially since nobody
speaks in the scene, instead quickly dispersing
to fight, and it doesn't really do anything
for the film's overall narrative.
No matter what some might think about the
scene, it was certainly an encouraging effort
from the MCU.
With plenty of female powerhouses coming up
in future films, the House of Heroes is sure
to make even more strides toward inclusivity
and representation.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.